pourquoi as tu choisi de te présenter à
cette élection pour savoir comment ça se
passe un peu dans le conseil pouvoir que
sont les différents métiers cupillard
des dents pour pour aider les jeunes
c'est pour avoir la vie des autres
jeunes et pourquoi on participe peu un
peu ce qui se passe à aurillac c'est
quoi selon toi un conseiller municipal
c'est une personne qui s'occupe de
beaucoup de choses à la fois qu'ils
essayent de faire de la ville quelque
chose de bien de mieux
quelqu'un d'organisé d'être
des sports à ville où des
deux français ils sont quatre mille cinq
cent soixante dix élèves scolarisés à
aurillac ont entre 11 et 16 ans et il se
prépare pour le grand jour le 19
novembre prochain où ils devront élire
les 39 premiers jeunes conseillers
municipaux d'auvergne véritable
assemblée représentative de la jeunesse
aurillacoise et reconnu comme tel ce
futur conseil municipal de jeunes sera
officiellement installé en janvier 88
une initiative qui dès le départ a su
faire l'unanimité tant au sein du
conseil municipal adultes que des
parents d'élèves et du corps enseignant
je pense que c'est une expérience que
qui sera enrichissante je l'espère du
moins pour les jeunes de dorian quelle a
été la réaction des élèves pour
l'instant on peut dire favorable
puisqu'il y a une vingtaine de candidats
pour ce qui concerne l'établissement est
alors que la clôture des inscriptions
est le 31 seulement pour vous est-ce que
c'est l'application pratique des
chroniques et scientifique c'est une
application pratique des cours à ce
sujet
hoofddorp c'est peut-être à l'heure
actuelle celle qui est la plus
importante au niveau du nombre d'élèves
concernés il ya plus de 4000 élèves qui
sont conscients quel sera le rôle de ce
conseil municipal des jeunes donnez donc
son avis sur les projets du conseil
municipal adulte faire des propositions
qui leur soit propre et puis ces
propositions pouvant être moins être
prise ensuite par le conseil municipal
adulte est ce que c'était un nouveau
défi pour la ville d'aurillac
puisqu'après le sport vous partez à la
conquête de la jeunesse et ça c'est bien
c'est un nouveau défi effectivement je
crois que les rapports entre le monde
des adultes et le monde de la jeunesse
sont parfois difficiles les adultes ont
du mal parfois à comprendre la jeunesse
les jeunes ne comprennent pas toujours
les adultes ceux ci des filiales c'est
effectivement pour essayer de de gagner
dans cette compréhension mutuelle entre
les jeunes et les adultes